ازمه حل التعديلات القضائيه تفتح سجالا
حادا وعلنيا هو الاول من نوعه في تاريخ
العلاقات بين الولايات المتحده واسرائيل
بعدما وجهت اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن رساله شديده اللهجه للحكومه
الاسرائيليه حذرت فيها من ان اسرائيل لا
يمكنها مواصله مسار المواجهه القضائيه
داعيه طبعا رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتانياهو للتوصل الى تسويه حقيقيه
واشنطن رفعت البطاقه الحمراء بوجه نتنياهو
بعدما قالها بايدن صراحه انه يعتزم عدم
دعوه نتنياهو الى البيت الابيض في المدى
القريب الامر الذي رد عليه الاخير معتبرا
ان اسرائيل دوله مستقله تتخذ قراراتها من
دون اي ضغوط خارجيه صحيفه اسرائيليه كانت
نقلت عن وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
التمار بتغفير قوله ان على الولايات
المتحده ان تدرك ان اسرائيل ليست نجمه في
العالم الامريكي وبالتالي هي دوله مستقله
وليست ولايه امريكيه
[موسيقى]